my thoughts at the end of day 42 can you
believe it America in shutdown now many
of you are probably feeling kind of like
I'm feeling it's it's a weird feeling
isn't it I mean it's it's horrible you
feel like all the people who suffered
out there you're also living in kind of
a time warp because you think back like
in the pre kovat days seems like kind of
a long time ago in a way you could do
things like drive to visit your friends
or maybe stop in to see your parents or
a relative you might have dropped your
child off at school or you could go out
on a Saturday night maybe go to a
ballgame maybe go to dinner now in the
pre Kovan world you didn't have to walk
around like you're playing medical
dress-up you shook hands when you met
someone or making a bet you hugged your
son's best friend when he made on a roll
you shook hands when you met someone for
the first time just what you did you
went to church maybe you even planned a
fun summer getaway you were making
decent money but six weeks after most of
us lost a lot of these freedoms this is
where things stand and our most populous
state well folks there seem to have had
enough about of the lockdown and talking
California their numbers well this is
where they are they've lost seventeen
hundred and seventy six of their
citizens to kovat in a state of 40
million that's nearly 45 people per
million now compared to 1145 per million
in New York think of that differential
that's reported twenty-two thousand five
hundred deaths by the way in New York
despite having half the population of
the Golden State now you talk about
deaths and it gets very sterile and it
like it doesn't mean anything of course
every death is tragic every life is it
replaceable that goes without saying
the California by comparison to a lot of
other states especially New Jersey New
York is doing far better with about one
twentieth of the Cova deaths of the
Empire State again people are seeing
this there they're not dumb the data
doesn't lie that data is what the data
is
so this is what the beaches look like in
California this weekend well governor
Newsom was some kind of unhappy the
images we saw over the weekend the
images down in Orange County and Ventura
County on our beaches those images are
an example of what not to see people
what not to do if we're going to make
the meaningful progress that we've made
in the last few weeks extend into the
next number of old number of weeks well
you're getting the sense that a lot of
people are just starting to tune him and
a lot of other blue state politicians
out as well well there are protests in
Las Vegas a massive caravan of people
showed up on the strip there and with
the sunshine in cabin fever hitting more
and more Americans just want to get on
with their lives they want to do it
safely but they have to get on with
their lives of course the media they're
there lying in wait you get the sense
that some might be ghoulishly watching
to see if states like Georgia remember
Georgia opened first whether they show a
major uptick in hospitalizations due to
covin but as one Georgia barber shop
owner told us on Friday it's a matter of
his survival as well I had no income for
the last two months I own three barber
shops I also cut hair myself and us
being out of work is no money coming in
and off so my question to the people out
there what what should we do should we
just let you know just sit back and just
wait for the government to bail us out
or that we have and be as safe as
possible and still you know make as much
money as we can and you know can just
play it safe meanwhile remember pre
kovat when this was a story the flu is
already widespread in five states and
last year at this point it wasn't
widespread anywhere the number of flu
cases that we're detecting is much
higher than we would expect to see at
this point in time in any an average
year see all that red I mean how could
you not that should be a red flag about
just how bad this year's flu season has
got
and back in early January before he
became a global superstar dr. Anthony
foul she told CNN that this flu season
was on track to be as severe as the
2017-2018 season which was the deadliest
in more than four decades he said the
initial indicators indicate it's not
gonna be a good season this is going to
be a bad season but after those initial
warnings the story seemed to kind of go
away this despite the fact that we know
that at least 169 children have died
this flu season
that's only second to the 188 who died
during that 2017-2018 season at least
three children have died due to kovat
now look at these graphs from early this
year this is some of the math there week
after week the mortality numbers and
influenza and pneumonia they call P and
I were climbing despite all this though
civilization didn't grind to a halt
schools didn't close we didn't even talk
about it now h1n1 the swine flu was
particularly vicious this year whereas
the B strain hit the young hardest now
look at this graph of just how bad the
flu season was look at where it went up
you can see in the graph that red as it
goes up and it goes up toward you know
the end of the week 16 which is in April
but it actually went up to epidemic
levels a little bit over that white line
before you would imagine those Cova
deaths were actually counted it was a
nasty season so it qualified as a
national epidemic week after week a
clover close to it now kovat is not the
flu we're not saying that it's a lot
more contagious and it's new it hits the
old hardest young relatively unscathed
by it relatively and according to
researchers there are as many as 33
mutations to Kovac Kovac 19 yet the
coded mortality rate we now know because
now we have the data is a fraction of
what a lot of the professionals the
experts told us it would be well it's
inconvenient truths like that that led
doctors Erickson
Masey he who join us in moments to
produce a video calling for California
to be reopened 0.03 chance of dying from
kovat in the state of California is that
does that necessitate sheltering in
place does that necessitate shutting
down medical systems does that
necessitate people being out of work
when you're a little child crawling on
the ground putting stuff in your mouth
viruses and bacteria come in you form an
antigen antibody complex this is how
your immune system is built you don't
take a small child put them in bubble
wrap in a room and say don't have a
healthy immune system
they also say they're hearing from
doctors discussing the possibility that
there is a confluence of deaths being
reported when someone dies in this
country right now they're not talking
about the high blood pressure the
diabetes the stroke they say did they
die from covet there's as you we've been
to hundreds of autopsies you you don't
talk about one thing you talk about Co
morbidities ER doctors now my friends
that I talk to say you know it's
interesting when I'm when I'm writing up
my death report I'm being pressured to
add Kovan why is that and then they came
to this conclusion something else is
going on here this is not about science
and it's not even about kovat when they
use the word safe the word safe if you
listen the word safe
that's about controlling you well big
science the medical establishment
whatever you want to call it it's
already come around coming after them
since their videos have gone sorry for
the pun viral those are my thoughts at
the end of day 42 America in shutdown